hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that happened yesterday
in round 4 of the pro chess League it is
a Wonderland representing uh Charlotte
cobras versus Magnus Carlsen
representing chess Bros it's an
incredible game uh where Magnus was so
close uh to the uh to defeat like uh on
the on the brink of defeat and yet he
pulled through incredible as it is but
uh I mean uh he is Magnus Carlsen and he
always manages to amaze us in a new ways
so let's check it out what happened in
this game and how did he escape the
position from the thumbnail so Liang has
the white pieces and he opens with E4
Magnus goes for the French defense he
plays Ponte E6 D4 with D5 and Knight the
C3 so the standard way of challenging
the French with Knight to F6 is the
classical variation and now not E5 but
first the bishop to G5 still the the
absolute main line with the characters
and E4 Knight captures and Knight B to
D7 and now uh usually Knight to F3 is
how you continue this you could also
play C3 there are some other moves you
can play Liang decides to trade off a
pair of knights first he plays Knight
captures on F6 check Magnus recaptures
and now only now Knight to F3 we have
Pawn to C5 a very principal striking
against White Center C3 and now Pawn to
A6 and there are a few moves uh that
have been played in this position for
example Judith Polgar played Knight to
the E5 here against the body Mill of uh
in 2005. the game ended in a draw but
here we have Bishop to D3 by I wonder
and it is now as of move nine that we
have a completely new game so Magnus
trades once C captures on D4 not C
captures we have Knight captures on D4
why not improve the position of your
knight if you can and pawn to H6
challenging the bishop here with Bishop
to H4 and now Magnus goes Bishop to C5
there's no reason to play Bishop to E7
just yet as it's a very hard to pile up
on that and Knight on F6 so here we have
Castles by both players castles castles
and now Knight B3 attacking the bishop
on C5 with Bishop back to E7 now and
queen to E2 developing the queen
preparing Rook 8 to D1 so of course
Magnus moves the queen to C7 and Bishop
to G3 now attacking the queen with
Bishop to D6 now now Conquering the the
dark Square bishop and The Rook 8 D1 now
putting pressure on the D6 bishop and
the Magnus is all right let's trade once
we have Bishop captures and G3 H
captures and G3 and now grabbing more
space in the center with E5 freeing up
his light Square Bishop Rook after E1
and now comes Rook to E8 and if you look
at the position both players can be very
happy with their position uh Liang has
everything he could remove he has a
beautifully placed Rooks on D1 and D1
the bishop and queen are excellently
placed at some point you wanna put your
queen on this diagonal and try to
Checkmate the black king where Magnus
will have to either weaken the position
with G6 or try to avoid the whole thing
basically all together and the other
thing the Knight on B3 is placed uh a
bit odd so combining the two ideas a
Liang presents us with his next move and
that is Knight to D2 so this gets rid of
the weird Knight on B3 he's preparing
Knight to the E4 he wants to eliminate
the Knight on F6 put the queen on e4 and
then go for Queen to H7 that's the short
term plan long term depends on what
Magnus plays so Bishop to G4 Magnus
develops with Tempo Pawn to F3 and now
Bishop back to E6 and I wonder continues
with Knight to E4 and now how do you
play this the problem is okay you could
of course play captures captures then
you have to play G6 already you've
weakened your position and now now the
H6 Pawn becomes weakened you give white
some some ideas of of how to continue
the attack which is not a bad way to go
but Magnus plays Queen to B6 check first
king the H2 and now Magnus says I'm not
interested in any uh uh you know two to
three move combinations I'm gonna play
this like an engine would he plays
Bishop captures on A2 and he completely
disregards the the Knight captures an F6
idea bringing the queen to E4 because he
says Knight captures on F6 I can play
Queen captures on F6 or so he thought uh
this is a bishop capture Sun A2 is not
the the greatest move in the position
and I wonder shows him why so feel free
to pause the video here and try to spot
the absolute best move for a Wonder uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
foreign
looking for wonderful ways to push that
B Pawn and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Pawn to B3
that's the way to go and now once you
see it of course you immediately believe
it because uh capturing with the queen
is out of the question if you capture
with the queen and you have to do
something because the bishop on A2 was
hanging then Rook day one and the bishop
is trapped you just blunder a piece here
so Magnus has to capture with the bishop
Bishop captures on B3 and now Rook to B1
now he has to be very careful otherwise
Bishop to C2 will just win that Bishop
on B3 as the bishop still cannot move so
Magnus is forced to play A5 here or or
queen T6 also possible uh he goes A5
wants to defend his Bishop with A4 but
now comes Knight captures on F6 and now
if Magnus doesn't want to give up the
bishop on B3 he has to mess up his uh
Pawn structure in front of the king so G
captures an F6 and and now Queen to E4
and I wonder wins this diagonal and
queen to H7 is coming and the way to
play this is you have to play King to f8
with King to fade your chances of
survival are existent but if you play
with Magnus played and that is Rook 8 to
C8 now the position is completely
winning for a Wonder because everything
comes with Tempo now look at this queen
to H7 with check we've reached the
position from the thumbnail King to f8
now Queen to H6 with check and there's a
big problem here uh King the E7 and King
to G8 both lose King to G8 loses much
faster because it's a force Checkmate
just Bishop H7 check and after King to
h8 okay you don't have the standard
Bishop G6 check Queen H7 check Queen to
F7 Checkmate because the bishop is
covering the F7 Pawn however you do have
Bishop to F5 check and once the King
goes to G8 okay the king cannot go to f8
now Rook E4 and there's no defense
against Rook to G4 now if play Rook to
C4 the bishop no longer covers the F7
pawn and now you go for this Checkmate
Bishop H7 checking h8 Bishop G6 King
Jade Queen H7 checking f8 and queen
captures an F7 Checkmate as the bishop
on B3 is now useless so Magnus has to
start running King to E7 but now look at
this Rook captures an E5 with check
magnets cannot recapture as the queen on
B6 would hang so he has to continue uh
Merrily on his way King to D7 now Bishop
to B5 check King to C7 and Rook captures
on E8 now of course if you capture the
bishop just recaptures so Queen captures
on B5 and now Rook captures on C8 with
check King captures on C8 and queen the
f8 with Chuck forcing the king back into
the middle of the board King to C7 and
now I wonder rushed it a little bit he
should have gone for Queen to E7 with
check not going for a queen captures on
F7 this way you gobble up everything and
you just enjoy a winning position let's
say King B6 now I play Queen captures
and F6 with check King A7 and only now
Queen characters and F7 where you force
um either Force the trade of queens or
you're gonna lose the bishop on B3 or
okay you can play A4 but now uh White is
up two pawns you can just start pushing
your G pawn and you will win the game
however I wonder rushed a little bit the
this rapid chest they were both in time
trouble already by this point he played
Queen captures on F7 which is of course
still winning for him but he gives
Magnus a chance to at least play the end
game which uh is not an easy uh thing to
do if you allow Magnus to play the end
game Bishop captures an F7 with Rook
captures on B5 and now Pawn to A4 the
pawn is now on a light square and the
bishop can defend it via Bishop to B3
and now Rook to A5 makes sense when
you're low on time you want to put the
Rook behind the pass Pawn when you first
start playing chess everyone will just
tell you put the Rook behind the pass
Pawn yeah either your own or your
opponent's Pawn but here it is not the
way to go here the best way to play is a
rook to B4 and now when Magnus defense
with Bishop to B3 now you start bringing
the king into the game and uh you will
very likely win this however after Rook
to A5 it's a bit different Bishop to B3
we have G4 now Leon wants to create a
pass Pawn on the king side B6 Now The
Rook is being chased away from the a
file of course uh Liang will keep the
Rook on the a file Rook A7 check King to
C6 by Magnus and now Pawn to F4 we have
Pawn to B5 uh and pawn to G file Leon
creates a pass Pawn on the king side
captures captures and now King the B6
again trying to get the Rook away from
the a file so Magnus can start pushing
that a pawn Rook to A8 and now King to
B7 and here if a Wonder wanted to he
could probably play Rook day 5 and
Magnus would be forced to accept
repetition here with something like King
to B6 Rook 8 and King to B7 but of
course Liang knows his position is
winning and he wants to keep the game
going Rook to E8 and now Pawn to A3 now
the pawn is coming to A2 and you're
never getting rid of that pawn we have
pawned the G6 still the the way to
attempt to win this with white is King
to G3 but after Pawn to G6 uh which does
really nothing Magnus does a pawn to A2
another problem is yes a Wonder has
three pawns but the bishop here pretty
much controls uh all three pawns and
there's nothing you can do about that
even if you promote the pawn Magnus will
just give up the bishop and promote his
Pawn to a queen so Rook the E1 you have
to play this and now King the C6 now
Magnus will eliminate this pawn move the
bishop and start advancing the B Pawn as
well and how do you do something with
your pawns there's really no way Pawn to
G7 Bishop to G8 now we have King to G3
now Avon a Wonder starts bringing the
king into the game King to D5 okay now
the bishop is not defending the pawn so
quickly Rook to A1 but now King the E4
again the bishop defends the pawn and
here we have King to G4
attempting a bit too much the way to
continue this was Rook to D1 and you
still probably draw this you cut off the
king from uh from going uh after after
the spawn and creating another pass Pawn
but a Wonder played King to G4 and now
comes King to D3 we have Pawn to C4
doesn't really do all that much but uh
okay Bishop captures on C4 we have King
to F5 Now Pawn to B4 now the B Pawn
starts marching forward uh Rook to C1
and now Bishop to G8 by Magnus again
playing absolute precise moves because
if you just play B3 here uh then Rook
characters on C4 and the white will win
the game because after uh you promote
the spawn to a queen uh also white
promotes the G Pawn to a queen and now
white is just winning so Magnus goes
back Bishop to G8 now comes King to F6
and now Pawn to B3 we have rooked to C8
trying to eliminate the bishop here but
Magnus is now of course the a pawn
promotes with checks so that's all there
is to it A1 Pawn uh Ponte one Queen this
comes with check and it was in this
position and move 54 that a Wonderland
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here you either give up
the pawn and then the bishop is defended
or you try to defend the pawn but the
problem is then comes Queen to A6 check
you lose the rook and C8 and that's all
there is there's no more uh playing this
for white so incredible incredible game
uh it's a shame I wonder wasn't able to
pull this off especially since after
played this uh so-called engine move
Bishop captures an A2 uh Ling didn't
just play play anything he found the
correct way to win the game uh upon the
B3 uh but uh he just couldn't continue
playing
um uh so ferociously until the very end
Magnus equalized and in the end in time
trouble Magnus was able to emerge
Victorious so incredible game and I mean
incredible when you just look at this
position Queen to H7 check the the black
can survive this look at this Rook
captures an E5 check it's a spectacular
King and the Magnus still escapes
um uh the the defeat and wins the game
absolutely incredible but it's rapid
chess not all the Time in the World to
plan your moves uh so this one went to
Magnus even though uh Liang played it
brilliantly he uh completely destroyed
the the French defense but even that
wasn't enough
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh be a beautiful game from
the from the round four of the pro chess
league if you have any games that you've
enjoyed from the protest League uh do uh
share them in the comment section using
hashtag suggestion I will go over them
uh and we'll check up uh some other
games if you still don't know uh there
is now a much easier way to search all
the videos that I've made on the channel
it's the first link in the description
below you can search by any uh criteria
uh you you desire uh so do do try it if
you still haven't it's a really uh uh
just uh a a beautiful uh piece of uh I
mean not technology but a beautiful
piece of programming uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank Kenneth Frazier the
buck will see this for trade Ricky black
and Cassius Johnson for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World like this game that
we've just seen from the protest League
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day